so that's my grand unified theory of why
people hate hyaluronic acid even though
it doesn't really deserve it it's
michelle of lamar from beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and pot
stirrer i asked people to give me their
hot takes and unpopular opinions about
skin care and beauty on instagram and
today i'm going to be responding to a
few of these some body moisturizers are
perfectly suitable for the face i
completely agree with this body and face
moisturizers are very similar in terms
of both formula as well as their
ingredients sometimes body moisturizers
are made to be heavier but some people
do need heavier moisturizing for their
face the biggest difference when it
comes to formulating a face versus a
body moisturizer is how it spreads with
a body moisturizer you try to make it
have a longer spread versus your face
which will have a shorter spread so what
this means is when you're putting it on
your body for example if you don't have
a long enough spread then it feels like
your hand just sort of keeps stopping
along your skin you might have noticed
this if you're trying to use up a face
cream on your body it just doesn't quite
feel like it's spreading quite right but
this isn't always an issue so it really
depends on the product itself and what
your skin needs and yeah body
moisturizers will probably work skin
care is unnecessary and our skin will
balance itself out if we leave it alone
okay this i think is definitely true for
a lot of people but definitely not true
for a lot of other people if you're
lucky enough to have skin that looks
after itself then good for you but there
are lots of things that can make
people's skin just not look after itself
properly for example dry skin is very
heavily genetic things like producing
too much pigment having acne hormonal
issues like pcos can be a cause of acne
as well you could argue that your skin
has evolved to look after itself over
millions of years but at the same time
we're in this period of rapid change
where we've changed the climate where
we're even sitting in things like we're
near air con or we're under heater a lot
of us are not living where our ancestors
evolved your skin also changes as you
age things don't work quite as well and
yeah again evolution hasn't really
caught up to that now there are
definitely some people who are using
skin care and they find that their skin
gets worse because you're messing with
something that you shouldn't be for
example i think a lot of people are
probably using moisturizer even though
they might not need it their skin is
producing enough oil and water and
they're just using it because they feel
like they should be but a lot of people
do need skin care to keep their skin
healthy and a lot of people might not
necessarily need skin care but after
using the right products they do see
their skin get healthier physical
exfoliation is terrible for sensitive
skin i disagree with this there is a lot
of slander about physical exfoliation
online and i need to defend it how harsh
physical exfoliation is depends a lot on
what exfoliant you're using and also how
hard you're pressing and also how long
you're using it for something like an
apricot scrub with walnut shell in it or
pumice in it is going to be on the
harsher end and that's usually what
people think of when they say physical
exfoliation and a lot of people who
aren't quite into skincare or they've
just started getting into skincare do
you tend to use harsher scrubs and in
that case i do agree that is really bad
for sensitive skin it is not going to
make your skin any better it will make
your skin worse almost for sure a lot of
these people are better off chucking
that scrub in the bin but gentle
physical exfoliation actually has some
benefits over chemical exfoliants first
off physical exfoliation only happens on
the surface and so you're not risking
anything deeper in terms of irritation
if you keep it very very gentle on the
top you also get immediate feedback on
when to stop so if you're putting on say
a chemical exfoliant and then you go off
you don't really notice that you've got
it on for too long or if you're using
something too harsh until it's kind of
too late to stop like you can wash it
off but a lot of it has penetrated and
will keep on working after you've washed
it off with physical exfoliation you
stop and the exfoliation stops there's
also the fact that physical exfoliation
isn't like
ingredients it doesn't have anything
that goes deep into your skin and so
there's going to be less potential
irritants and allergens so i think
really it's about getting to know these
gentler forms of physical exfoliation so
there's things like washcloths peeling
gels which are some of my favorite
products peeling gels have
usually cellulose or some sort of carbon
in it that will bunch up and it turns
into
very soft scrubbing grains so sort of
like a scrub except instead of harsh
particles you have these soft little
almost like fibers of fabric except not
fabric
i find that they work really well and if
i use chemical exfoliation without also
using a peeling gel then my skin just
isn't quite as good there's also konjac
sponges which i think have gotten less
popular but i think it's quite sad
because they are actually really awesome
they're like these soft little jelly
sponges that exfoliate really gently i
have an exfoliation guide that's linked
in the description so check that out if
you're looking at other ways of
exfoliating so i think people do tend to
over focus on chemical exfoliation but
there's a lot of other methods as well
so physical as well as enzyme exfoliants
which can be really good if you use them
all together
not over exfoliating in your routine
hyaluronic acid is overrated can cause
inflammation hope the trend should be
over because it's everywhere okay i do
think hyaluronic acid is maybe overrated
and it is maybe everywhere but i also
see a lot of these sort of
fear-mongering myths around it so
yeah let's talk about this whole
inflammation thing there are zero
studies showing that hyaluronic acid in
skincare is inflammatory when you put it
on your skin there's actually some
studies that find that hyaluronic acid
is anti-inflammatory
when you put it on things like wounds it
also doesn't make a lot of physiological
sense that it could be inflammatory when
you put it on your skin in a skin care
product so the reasoning is there is
hyaluronic acid in your body in a lot of
places specifically in your skin it's in
the lower layers and it's called a gag
hyaluronic acid is like a long polymer
and when it breaks then your body senses
these smaller particles of hyaluronic
acid and it senses that something is
damaged and needs to be repaired so
these little particles can signal that
you need to create some inflammation for
repair but when you're using it in
skincare you put it on the top of your
skin the top layers of your skin are
dead and your skin doesn't let in large
molecules in very deeply there's this
very rough rule of thumb that molecules
have to have a molecular weight that's
smaller than 500 daltons to absorb
deeply into skin there are exceptions to
this but if you go off and look up
buying very low molecular weight
hyaluronic acid it is around 10 000
daltons which is 20 times bigger which
means it is very unlikely to penetrate
on top of that hyaluronic acid is really
water soluble and things that absorb
deeply into skin need to be a good
balance between water and oil soluble
before they can absorb deeply because
your skin is both oily and watery it
doesn't let anything very far on either
end of the spectrum through very easily
so it's just really unlikely that even
very low molecular weight hyaluronic
acid is going to absorb deep enough to
trigger any sort of inflammation this is
like the same sort of reasoning for why
collagen creams don't really add to the
collagen in your skin because it's just
too big it doesn't absorb deep enough
this is a really common problem in
skincare a lot of these studies that are
showing the mechanism how an ingredient
could potentially work in skin doesn't
take into account the pharmacokinetics
which is whether or not that ingredient
actually can get to where it needs to go
before working also a lot of products
get clinically tested before they get
launched so this is things like checking
if they actually cause inflammation this
is especially the case when it comes to
those really big drugstore brands that
have really big research teams they're
always really careful about releasing
products that cause inflammation because
so many people will just go to the
supermarket and pick them up and start
using them and enough of these brands
have been using hyaluronic acid for
decades that i just don't think it's a
big concern they wouldn't be using it if
they were like consistent signs of
significant inflammation okay
more hyaluronic acid slander hyaluronic
acid dries the skin more if you don't
use it properly and live in a dry
climate i don't even like hyaluronic
acid that much but
i need to defend it i've seen this and
versions of this with other humectants
for basically all 10 years i've been
talking about skincare this has even
been mentioned in lots of peer-reviewed
studies as well as dermatology textbooks
now i have been looking at this for a
really long time and a lot of my
scientist friends have as well and every
time we try to trace it back to where
they got this information from so we
look up the references that they
reference we look up that reference
see who they reference and then just try
to trace it back
it always ends up as a study which
doesn't actually have a reference or
it's not actually on skin or it's just
not correct so as far as i know and as
far as all the scientists i've talked to
seem to know there is no actual evidence
of this happening on human skin i think
this comes from studies where they put
hyaluronic acid on a relatively small
thing so like a piece of glass for
example and they put it in a controlled
chamber which has a set humidity and
temperature and the hyaluronic acid
dried out but skin is very different
from a piece of glass your deeper layers
of skin have up to about i think 60
water and it keeps on getting more and
more water from your blood which is
flowing through like the blood vessels
oh yeah the blood vessels keep on
supplying water to the lower layers of
skin which slowly come up through the
top these lower laser skin have so much
more water than air these percentages
i'm talking about aren't the same as the
relative humidity so
even if the air has a hundred percent
relative humidity there is still way way
more water in your skin so humectants
are always getting most of their water
from your skin and never from the air
there's also water evaporating from your
skin all the time this is called
trans-epidermal water loss so the
hyaluronic acid and other humectants can
catch onto this water now i think with
how people use them then there is a good
point there some people are using
hyaluronic acid pretty much on its own
thinking it is so great at hydrating and
it's just not very well rounded if
you're trying to moisturize your skin
you can't really just use one humectant
it's much more effective if you also
have occlusives and emollients to get
well-rounded hydration like having all
three of those main categories of
moisturizer there's also the fact that
hyaluronic acid doesn't work as well as
some other humectants like glycerin
glycerin works in several ways it
doesn't just hold on to water it also
can go deeper into skin and change how
the skin's water gets distributed so
maybe if you're comparing hyaluronic
acid to glycerin then your expectations
are just a bit too high there's also the
fact that if you have larger molecules
of hyaluronic acid it tends to sit on
top of skin and it forms a film and when
that film starts to dry and
settle and turn into a film then you can
feel it on your skin and it feels a bit
like your skin is tight and dry so
that's my grand unified theory of why
people hate hyaluronic acid even though
it doesn't really deserve it if anyone
has any leads or solid evidence on
hyaluronic acid being inflammatory in
your skin or drying out skin then please
send them my way vitamin c is overrated
antioxidant love superoxide dismutase
pygnogenol resveratrol okay i have a
problem with this i'm a big fan of
vitamin c i've seen people say similar
stuff about how you can just replace
vitamin c with other antioxidants
problem one is antioxidants aren't all
the same antioxidants are ingredients
that can neutralize free radicals but
they have different abilities to
neutralize free radicals there are lots
of different free radicals and yeah
different antioxidants can react with
different ones to different extents also
most antioxidants have actually only
been tested in vitro so you don't know
whether or not it will actually get into
skin to where it needs to be to actually
work and do what you needed to do the
reason vitamin c has such a good
reputation is that it has the most
robust amount of evidence for being an
antioxidant in skin for example there's
the studies where it's reduced sunburn
there's also a whole bunch of skin model
studies which aren't quite as good as
actual clinical trials on humans but
there's still a lot more in vitamin c
than
every other antioxidant so for example
for the antioxidants they've named here
there are no peer-reviewed clinical
trials on actual human skin with
pycnogenol or resveratrol in skincare so
placing it on the skin there are some
supplement trials but supplements are
very different from skin care superoxide
diss me taste there is a study on that
for each but it doesn't seem to be
working via its antioxidant effect so
yet the level of evidence for vitamin c
versus everything else is just not the
same problem two is that vitamin c is
much more than just an antioxidant it
also boosts collagen and it reduces
pigment and those two actions don't look
like they're just because of its
antioxidant effects now i do understand
when people can't use it many formulas
of ascorbic acid on the market are quite
irritating and so you can use some other
ingredients instead to get your i guess
overall goals and lack of evidence
doesn't necessarily mean that something
doesn't work and maybe you just
personally get better results from
products that have these ingredients and
not vitamin c but saying that these
ingredients can be compared to vitamin c
as an antioxidant is yeah there's just
not that much evidence for it i really
don't think they're comparable what
western consumers buy as k beauty isn't
authentic compared to what's sold in
korea yeah i agree that this is probably
true but i don't know if it's really a
problem i think authenticity just for
the sake of authenticity is really
overrated so i'm chinese and i don't
know a single chinese person who thinks
sweet and sour pork is better without
the pineapple western taste isn't the
same as korean taste so for example
those tone up sunscreens they purposely
have a little bit of white cast because
in korea people like to be a little bit
whiter when they put on their makeup
but i don't want it i don't want to look
whiter i don't think most western
consumers want it either i guess if your
reason for liking k-beauty is that it's
exotic and you're into korean stuff or
you think that korean people are
magically wise when it comes to skin
care then
yeah maybe you should look up the best
sellers in korea and use those rather
than what's being shown by western
influences but in reality the korean
bestsellers are also susceptible to a
lot of marketing for example right now
the ewg is a really big thing in korean
marketing and
as you hopefully know from watching my
channel
their stuff is just complete
pseudoscience it's okay to miss a day of
wearing sunscreen yes i completely agree
with this getting really anxious about
missing a single day of sunscreen is
usually not really worth it obviously
i'm not talking about like a 12-hour day
where you're running around on the beach
and getting massively sunburned that is
probably not a good idea and if you are
getting severely sunburned you are
increasing your risk of skin cancer but
if you're just having very low uv
exposure that day like maybe you're
going to the office or you had a short
walk in the winter then it's probably
fine you've probably skipped a lot of
days of sunscreen before you discovered
skin care one extra day of skipping it
is not going to set you all the way back
if you do find yourself skipping a lot
of days though then it might be good to
consider if you have a backup plan it
might be good to think about how you can
develop a habit of wearing sunscreen you
might want to keep some sun protective
clothing in your car or keep sunscreen
in your handbag just as much
misinformation comes from chemists as
well i think this comment is saying
compared to dermatologists and i would
disagree not because i think chemists
are more correct or right all the time
but just because there are a lot less
chemists saying things on large
platforms i have definitely seen some
chemists saying very incorrect stuff in
magazine articles and on social media i
actually read a bunch of sunscreen
magazine articles recently for an
instagram post and
it was pretty bad but for every chemist
i came across who was interviewed there
were like 25 dermatologists interviewed
so just based on the volume alone i
don't think it is possible for chemists
to be contributing as much to
misinformation but i definitely agree
with the sentiment of this opinion you
shouldn't trust information just because
it comes from someone with a
qualification including me you should be
checking against other sources i'm sick
of single star ingredient products
honestly me too i like a well-rounded
multi-functional skincare product i'm a
bit of a minimalist and i like having
less products in my routine if i can get
everything i want in the one product
then i'm going to use that product i do
think single ingredient products are
quite good because they're customizable
so if you have particular allergies or
particular sensitivities you can avoid
ingredients you don't like or at least
you can avoid them more easily you can
try an ingredient on its own and get an
idea of how that works although even
then it doesn't give a great indication
for example with niacinamide my skin
didn't really love the ordinary's one
but it really liked the paula's choice
product so i actually gave up on
niacinamide at the start because the
single ingredient one was the first one
i tried and it just didn't seem to do
much it was just that particular product
just wasn't formulated in a way that was
going to help my skin so i can
understand why people like single
ingredient products but i personally
would much prefer a well-rounded product
that has a bunch of suitable actives and
yeah i'm much more likely to use that
but at the same time it can be hard to
find a well-rounded product that fits
all of your criteria there is a lot more
trial and error involved i hope you
enjoyed this chat leave me your
unpopular opinions in the comments and
maybe i'll use them in a future video
like subscribe follow more videos are
popping up around me